This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2022, a group of developers in San Francisco proposed turning a Nordstrom parking lot into housing. They wanted to build nearly 500 apartments, many of them affordable, right near public transit. But before they could even start the formal approval process, they had to go through what's called a preliminary review.
This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2022, a group of developers in San Francisco proposed turning a Nordstrom parking lot into housing. They wanted to build nearly 500 apartments, many of them affordable, right near public transit. But before they could even start the formal approval process, they had to go through what's called a preliminary review.|||这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2022年，旧金山的一群开发商提议将诺德斯特龙百货公司的停车场改建成住宅。他们希望在靠近公共交通的地方建造近500套公寓，其中许多是经济适用房。但在他们甚至开始正式审批流程之前，他们必须经历所谓的初步审查。
That's when city planners take a first look and tell you what studies, hearings, and permits your project will need. It's not a green light to build. It's not even a red light. It's just a list of what paperwork you'll need to file. And that step alone took over 500 days. That kind of delay isn't rare. All over the country, efforts to build housing, transit, and clean energy get tangled up in
That's when city planners take a first look and tell you what studies, hearings, and permits your project will need. It's not a green light to build. It's not even a red light. It's just a list of what paperwork you'll need to file. And that step alone took over 500 days. That kind of delay isn't rare. All over the country, efforts to build housing, transit, and clean energy get tangled up in|||那是城市规划者进行初步审查并告诉你项目需要哪些研究、听证会和许可证的时候。这并不是开工的绿灯。甚至算不上红灯。它只是一份你需要提交的文件清单。而仅这一步就花了500多天。这种延误并不罕见。在全国各地，建造住房、交通和清洁能源的努力都陷入了……
procedures that are supposed to help, but often just stall everything. Ezra Klein has been thinking about this a lot. His new book that he co-authored with Derek Thompson is called Abundance, and at its core, it's about infrastructure. Not just roads and bridges, but the systems that make it possible or impossible to build anything at all. He argues that the biggest obstacles to building the stuff we need aren't technological or financial, they're legal and procedural, and they're largely self-imposed. His book, which came out a couple months ago,
procedures that are supposed to help, but often just stall everything. Ezra Klein has been thinking about this a lot. His new book that he co-authored with Derek Thompson is called Abundance, and at its core, it's about infrastructure. Not just roads and bridges, but the systems that make it possible or impossible to build anything at all. He argues that the biggest obstacles to building the stuff we need aren't technological or financial, they're legal and procedural, and they're largely self-imposed. His book, which came out a couple months ago,|||本意是提供帮助却往往只会让一切停滞的程序中。埃兹拉·克莱因一直在深入思考这个问题。他和德里克·汤普森合著的新书名为《丰裕》，其核心就是关于基础设施。不仅仅是道路和桥梁，还有那些让一切建造变为可能或不可能的系统。他认为，建造我们所需之物最大的障碍不是技术或资金上的，而是法律和程序上的，而且很大程度上是作茧自缚。他的书几个月前刚出版，
has been making waves and causing arguments, and so we wanted to have him on the show to talk about it. So for people who are not familiar with the book, tell us about the idea of abundance. What does it look like? So the idea of abundance is, there is a pretty simple question that would be good to put back at the center of abundance is there is a pretty simple question that would be good to put
has been making waves and causing arguments, and so we wanted to have him on the show to talk about it. So for people who are not familiar with the book, tell us about the idea of abundance. What does it look like? So the idea of abundance is, there is a pretty simple question that would be good to put back at the center of abundance is there is a pretty simple question that would be good to put|||在坊间掀起了波澜并引发了争论，所以我们想请他上节目来谈谈这个话题。那么，对于不熟悉这本书的人，请给我们讲讲“丰裕”的概念。它是什么样子的？所以丰裕的概念是，有一个非常简单的问题，最好能重新回到……丰裕的核心是一个非常简单的问题，最好能将其置于……
back at the center of politics, which is what do we need more of and how do we get it? And that emerges from looking around California, looking around the federal government, looking around America itself and seeing that a lot of our problems are problems of scarcity, problems of being unable to build enough of the things we need. Housing, clean energy, infrastructure. And you would think this is pretty straightforward. I mean, what is politics about if not getting enough of what we need?
back at the center of politics, which is what do we need more of and how do we get it? And that emerges from looking around California, looking around the federal government, looking around America itself and seeing that a lot of our problems are problems of scarcity, problems of being unable to build enough of the things we need. Housing, clean energy, infrastructure. And you would think this is pretty straightforward. I mean, what is politics about if not getting enough of what we need?|||政治的中心，那就是我们更需要什么以及我们如何得到它？这源于环顾加州、环顾联邦政府、环顾美国本土后发现，我们的许多问题都是短缺的问题，是无法建造足够所需之物的问题。住房、清洁能源、基础设施。你可能会觉得这很简单。我的意思是，政治不就是为了满足我们的需求吗？
But actually you dig into it and you dig into how we run our governments and make our laws and build our processes. And you often find that we are the reason we are not building enough houses. We are the reason we are not building enough clean energy or transmission lines. And so it's an effort to focus people on that set of questions to try to like pump out some more utopian thinking about what world
But actually you dig into it and you dig into how we run our governments and make our laws and build our processes. And you often find that we are the reason we are not building enough houses. We are the reason we are not building enough clean energy or transmission lines. And so it's an effort to focus people on that set of questions to try to like pump out some more utopian thinking about what world|||但实际上，当你深入探究，深入了解我们如何管理政府、制定法律和构建流程时。你往往会发现，我们正是我们没有建造足够房屋的原因。我们就是我们没有建造足够的清洁能源或输电线路的原因。因此，这是一种努力，旨在让人们关注这一系列问题，试图催生一些关于我们想要生活在什么样的世界中的乌托邦式思考，
do we want to inhabit and then work backwards of what is plentiful there that is scarce here and how do we bridge the gap? So what is stopping us from this vision of abundance? What stands in the way? It depends on the issue. So not every domain is the same, not every place is the same.
do we want to inhabit and then work backwards of what is plentiful there that is scarce here and how do we bridge the gap? So what is stopping us from this vision of abundance? What stands in the way? It depends on the issue. So not every domain is the same, not every place is the same.|||然后倒推：那里丰富而这里稀缺的是什么，我们又该如何弥合这一差距？那么，是什么阻止了我们实现这种丰裕的愿景呢？是什么挡在了前面？这取决于具体的问题。因此，并非每个领域都一样，也并非每个地方都一样。
But you don't have enough apartments in San Francisco because we made it functionally illegal to build apartments in San Francisco, right? It's not like San Francisco has lost the knowledge that Houston still has about how to build an apartment building It's not like we don't have any cranes We just don't make it possible and there's a million different reasons why but fundamentally we have constructed A set of processes to make it impossible. Why did we not get world broadband done under Joe Biden or the electric vehicle chargers? It's a different set of problems, but we've made the process much too heavy. We've made it too expensive. We've made it too cumbersome. We've created too many veto points.
But you don't have enough apartments in San Francisco because we made it functionally illegal to build apartments in San Francisco, right? It's not like San Francisco has lost the knowledge that Houston still has about how to build an apartment building It's not like we don't have any cranes We just don't make it possible and there's a million different reasons why but fundamentally we have constructed A set of processes to make it impossible. Why did we not get world broadband done under Joe Biden or the electric vehicle chargers? It's a different set of problems, but we've made the process much too heavy. We've made it too expensive. We've made it too cumbersome. We've created too many veto points.|||但是你在旧金山没有足够的公寓，是因为我们在实际上把在旧金山建造公寓定为非法了，对吧？并不是说旧金山失去了休斯顿仍然保留的关于如何建造公寓楼的知识，也不是说我们没有任何起重机，我们只是让它无法实现，其中有上百万个不同的原因，但根本上来说，我们构建了一套让它无法实现的流程。为什么在乔·拜登的领导下，我们没有完成全球宽带或电动汽车充电桩的建设？这是一组不同的问题，但我们把流程搞得太沉重了。我们把它搞得太昂贵了。我们把它搞得太繁琐了。我们创造了太多的否决点。
And every one of these things has its own little history. They're, you know, as I say about the families, right, they're unhappy in their own ways, but they reflect a generalized embrace of the virtues of delay. And the virtues of delay, depending on what process you're looking for, tend to be about amassing more information so that some group, some constituency, some problem is not missed. The issue is that when you do that, you create a leverage point for anybody who wants to stop what is actually going on, right? So, you know, what in theory you're doing is checking to see if there's gonna be negative
And every one of these things has its own little history. They're, you know, as I say about the families, right, they're unhappy in their own ways, but they reflect a generalized embrace of the virtues of delay. And the virtues of delay, depending on what process you're looking for, tend to be about amassing more information so that some group, some constituency, some problem is not missed. The issue is that when you do that, you create a leverage point for anybody who wants to stop what is actually going on, right? So, you know, what in theory you're doing is checking to see if there's gonna be negative|||而这里面的每一件事都有它自己的小历史。它们，你知道的，正如我对家庭的评价一样，它们有各自的不幸，但它们反映了对拖延美德的普遍拥抱。而拖延的美德，取决于你所关注的流程，往往是为了收集更多信息，以便不会错过某个群体、某个选区或某个问题.问题在于，当你这样做时，你为任何想要阻止正在发生的事情的人创造了一个借力点，对吧？所以，你知道的，理论上你在做的是检查是否会产生负面的……
environmental consequences from a project. But what then people are doing is using that process and using the lawsuits that process makes possible to make the project not happen at all. They're not worried about protecting the snail. They're worried about the fact that they just don't want this built in the first place. And this gives them a way to slow the project down so much that it becomes too costly to ever create in the first place.
environmental consequences from a project. But what then people are doing is using that process and using the lawsuits that process makes possible to make the project not happen at all. They're not worried about protecting the snail. They're worried about the fact that they just don't want this built in the first place. And this gives them a way to slow the project down so much that it becomes too costly to ever create in the first place.|||项目的环境后果。但人们实际在做的是，利用这一流程以及该流程可能带来的诉讼，让这个项目彻底泡汤。他们并不是担心保护蜗牛。他们担心的是，他们打从一开始就不想建这个项目。这给了他们一种方法，把项目拖慢到如此地步，以至于一开始就变得成本高昂得无法建造。
So at some point you have to look and realize that a policy architecture that got built for many different reasons in the 70s and 80s, you know, 90s has just kind of become overgrown that the problems we were trying to solve through that architecture have now created new problems and now we have to do a new era of institutional renewal that is alive to the issues of our age, not captured by the debates of a prior age. Right. So I get that the, you know, the process of slowing things down is sort of very specific
So at some point you have to look and realize that a policy architecture that got built for many different reasons in the 70s and 80s, you know, 90s has just kind of become overgrown that the problems we were trying to solve through that architecture have now created new problems and now we have to do a new era of institutional renewal that is alive to the issues of our age, not captured by the debates of a prior age. Right. So I get that the, you know, the process of slowing things down is sort of very specific|||所以在某个时刻，你必须审视并意识到，在70年代和80年代、你知道的90年代，出于各种不同原因建立的政策架构，现在已经变得杂草丛生，我们试图通过该架构解决的问题现在已经引发了新的问题，现在我们必须开启一个机构更新的新时代，这个新时代要敏锐地意识到我们这个时代的议题，而不是被前一个时代的争论所束缚。没错。所以，我明白，你知道的，放慢脚步的过程在某种程度上是非常具体的……
to whatever it is you're trying to slow down and all those sort of get clued up in their very specific ways. If we were to pick one, I was thinking of picking high-speed rail because it's sort of a centerpiece at the beginning of your book. What is the project there and how was it getting stopped? So, high-speed rail. High-speed rail is a good one because I think it sounds a little bit futuristic to people. Yeah. But other countries have built high speed rail. You can ride high speed rail all around Europe, you can ride it around Japan, you can ride it in China. China in recent decades has built 23,000 miles of high speed rail.
to whatever it is you're trying to slow down and all those sort of get clued up in their very specific ways. If we were to pick one, I was thinking of picking high-speed rail because it's sort of a centerpiece at the beginning of your book. What is the project there and how was it getting stopped? So, high-speed rail. High-speed rail is a good one because I think it sounds a little bit futuristic to people. Yeah. But other countries have built high speed rail. You can ride high speed rail all around Europe, you can ride it around Japan, you can ride it in China. China in recent decades has built 23,000 miles of high speed rail.|||针对你试图放慢速度的任何事物，所有这些事物都以它们非常独特的方式被串联起来。如果我们必须挑选一个，我一直在考虑挑选高速铁路，因为它算是你书开头的一个核心内容。那里的项目是什么，它是如何被阻止的？所以，高速铁路。高铁是个不错的例子，因为我觉得它对人们来说听起来有点未来感。是的。但其他国家已经修建了高铁。你可以在全欧洲坐高铁，你可以在日本坐高铁，你可以在中国坐高铁。中国在最近几十年来修建了2.3万英里（约3.7万公里）的高铁。
California begins studying high speed rail in the 80s. It passes in 2008. I think it's fair to mark this as like the real beginning, this proposition that sets aside a bunch of money for it. And they say it's going to take them till about, you know, 2020 ish and cost about $33 billion. And here we are in 2025. You can't ride anything. The cost estimate if you were to finish the whole thing is now $110 billion. And what they're only trying to do is this Merced Bakersfield line, which will cost you know, more than the whole thing is now $110 billion. And what they're only trying to do is this Merced Bakersfield line, which will cost more than the whole thing was initially believed to cost.
California begins studying high speed rail in the 80s. It passes in 2008. I think it's fair to mark this as like the real beginning, this proposition that sets aside a bunch of money for it. And they say it's going to take them till about, you know, 2020 ish and cost about $33 billion. And here we are in 2025. You can't ride anything. The cost estimate if you were to finish the whole thing is now $110 billion. And what they're only trying to do is this Merced Bakersfield line, which will cost you know, more than the whole thing is now $110 billion. And what they're only trying to do is this Merced Bakersfield line, which will cost more than the whole thing was initially believed to cost.|||加州在80年代开始研究高铁。它于2008年通过。我认为将其标记为真正的开始是公平的，即为它拨出一大笔钱的提案。他们说这大约需要到2020年左右，成本约为330亿美元。而现在我们来到了2025年。你什么也坐不上。如果要完成整个项目，现在的成本估计是1100亿美元。而他们现在正试图做的只是默塞德到贝克斯菲尔德的这条线路，它的成本将……你知道的，比最初认为整个项目所需的成本还要高。
So what happens in the interim? There is no end of problems. But what I would say is that the connective tissue of them is that everything, everything, everything is a negotiation and delay. The route, the individual environmental clearances in 2012, they begin trying to do environmental clearance on the route. That isn't done by the end of 2024. In every city, there's sort of, not literally every city,
So what happens in the interim? There is no end of problems. But what I would say is that the connective tissue of them is that everything, everything, everything is a negotiation and delay. The route, the individual environmental clearances in 2012, they begin trying to do environmental clearance on the route. That isn't done by the end of 2024. In every city, there's sort of, not literally every city,|||那么在此期间发生了什么？问题层出不穷。但我要说的是，将它们连接在一起的纽带是：一切，一切，一切都是谈判和拖延。路线、个别的环境许可——在2012年，他们开始尝试对路线进行环境许可审查。到2024年底还没完成。在每个城市，都有某种……也不是字面意义上的每个城市，
but a lot of the cities, they're making side deals to come in and rebuild a playground or do this so that the council and so on will not fight them too much in places where they need to go through land. The eminent domain process is actually extremely cumbersome. What you begin to see with high speed rail, because I mean, we could sit here and talk about it for hours, but what you begin to see is almost no matter which part of the kaleidoscope you look at it through, there is not a process that allows the government to build things and it is decided are priorities.
but a lot of the cities, they're making side deals to come in and rebuild a playground or do this so that the council and so on will not fight them too much in places where they need to go through land. The eminent domain process is actually extremely cumbersome. What you begin to see with high speed rail, because I mean, we could sit here and talk about it for hours, but what you begin to see is almost no matter which part of the kaleidoscope you look at it through, there is not a process that allows the government to build things and it is decided are priorities.|||但很多城市都在做幕后交易，进来重建一个游乐场或做类似的事情，这样市议会等机构在他们需要征用土地的地方就不会过多地为难他们。土地征用（敲诈/征收）程序实际上极其繁琐。关于高铁，你开始看到的是——因为我的意思是，我们可以坐在这里谈论几个小时，但你开始看到的是，几乎无论你通过万花筒的哪个部分来看它，都没有一个程序能允许政府去建造那些被决定为优先事项的东西。
The government does not have the power to say, we are going to build high speed rail. This is going to create inconveniences. It is important to us that we are going to move fast and organize resources in a rapid way to get it done. Instead, they're negotiating with other parts of government. They're in endless lawsuits, they are sort of redoing the route relentlessly because like this or that group doesn't like it or this or that legislator doesn't like it.
The government does not have the power to say, we are going to build high speed rail. This is going to create inconveniences. It is important to us that we are going to move fast and organize resources in a rapid way to get it done. Instead, they're negotiating with other parts of government. They're in endless lawsuits, they are sort of redoing the route relentlessly because like this or that group doesn't like it or this or that legislator doesn't like it.|||政府没有权力说：“我们要修建高铁。这会带来不便。对我们来说重要的是，我们要迅速行动，以快速的方式组织资源来完成它。”相反，他们在与其他政府部门谈判。他们陷入了无休止的诉讼中，他们因为这个或那个群体不喜欢、或者这个或那个立法者不喜欢，而在无休止地重新规划路线。
And what you have here, you have it in other states too in different ways, but you begin to see, oh, we can't do it. There are a million things that I disagree with Elon Musk on and he's become a very poisonous political figure, but he does give this interview, you know, a bit back where he says about high speed rail in California that we have functionally made it illegal to build high speed rail in California. And that's accurate. That's the right way to think about it. We've created a process by which it would not be legal to do the things you need to
And what you have here, you have it in other states too in different ways, but you begin to see, oh, we can't do it. There are a million things that I disagree with Elon Musk on and he's become a very poisonous political figure, but he does give this interview, you know, a bit back where he says about high speed rail in California that we have functionally made it illegal to build high speed rail in California. And that's accurate. That's the right way to think about it. We've created a process by which it would not be legal to do the things you need to|||而你在这里看到的，在其他州也以不同的方式存在着，但你开始发现：哦，我们做不到。我和埃隆·马斯克有数百万件意见不合的事，他已经成了一个极具毒性的政治人物，但他前不久确实做过一次这样的访谈，他在访谈中谈到加州的高铁时说，我们在实际上让在加州修建高铁成了非法的。这是准确的。这才是思考它的正确方式。我们创造了一个程序，按照这个程序，去做你必须去做的事情将是不合法的……
do to build high speed rail. So then you want to ask this question, right? Do you think that it is an abuse of democracy the way Spain or France or Japan does rail construction? Or do you think it is an abuse of democracy to make things that the public wants so unbelievably subject to veto and delay that they never happen? That's really the choice, I think, that emerges through studying this particular project closely. Are people obstructing just to obstruct?
do to build high speed rail. So then you want to ask this question, right? Do you think that it is an abuse of democracy the way Spain or France or Japan does rail construction? Or do you think it is an abuse of democracy to make things that the public wants so unbelievably subject to veto and delay that they never happen? That's really the choice, I think, that emerges through studying this particular project closely. Are people obstructing just to obstruct?|||以建造高铁。所以你就会想问这个问题，对吧？你认为西班牙、法国或日本建造铁路的方式是对民主的滥用吗？还是你认为，让公众想要的东西变得如此难以置信地容易遭到否决和拖延以至于永远无法实现，才是对民主的滥用？我认为，这正是通过仔细研究这个特定项目而浮现出的选择。人们阻挠纯粹是为了阻挠吗？
What is the nature of the obstruction? It depends. I mean, the problem is they have a million different reasons. Sometimes they are using the process exactly as intended. They are genuinely concerned that this or that project or this or that part of high speed rail will be devastating to the environment in some way or another. And so they're using environmental laws to try to change that or at least make the government
What is the nature of the obstruction? It depends. I mean, the problem is they have a million different reasons. Sometimes they are using the process exactly as intended. They are genuinely concerned that this or that project or this or that part of high speed rail will be devastating to the environment in some way or another. And so they're using environmental laws to try to change that or at least make the government|||阻挠的本质是什么？这要看情况。我的意思是，问题在于他们有一百万个不同的理由。有时他们完全按照最初的设计来使用这个程序。他们真心担心这个或那个项目，或者高铁的这个或那个部分会在某种程度上对环境造成破坏。因此，他们利用环境法来试图改变这一点，或者至少让政府……
think about the consequences of the action and ameliorate it. Elsewhere, it's not that at all. So the California Environmental Quality Act, which is a sort of statewide version of a national policy. One of the reasons that act, which is a sort of statewide version of a national policy. One of the reasons that act, which is widely agreed in California to be kind of a disaster is very, very hard to change, is that California's unions defend it relentlessly. Now, why do they defend it? Because I mean, they're not primarily motivated by environmental concerns. They defend it because they use CEQA to basically threaten delay in lawsuit if developers for
think about the consequences of the action and ameliorate it. Elsewhere, it's not that at all. So the California Environmental Quality Act, which is a sort of statewide version of a national policy. One of the reasons that act, which is a sort of statewide version of a national policy. One of the reasons that act, which is widely agreed in California to be kind of a disaster is very, very hard to change, is that California's unions defend it relentlessly. Now, why do they defend it? Because I mean, they're not primarily motivated by environmental concerns. They defend it because they use CEQA to basically threaten delay in lawsuit if developers for|||思考该行为的后果并加以改善。而在其他地方，根本就不是这样。因此，《加利福尼亚州环境质量法案》（CEQA），它是国家政策的一种全州版本。该法案——它在某种程度上是国家政策的全州版本。该法案在加州被普遍认为是一场地灾难，而且非常非常难以改变，原因之一就是加州的工会无休止地捍卫它。那么他们为什么要捍卫它呢？因为我的意思是，他们的主要动机不是出于对环境的担忧。他们捍卫它是为了利用CEQA基本上以延误和诉讼相威胁，如果开发商在……
all kinds of different projects don't make sufficient concessions to the union or don't unionize the project or whatever. And so they've become a huge defender of this, not because of its environmental quality dimensions, but because it is a point of leverage they can use for labor standards. Now, I'm broadly speaking pro-union, but I would like to use like direct worker law to effectuate that, not have these sort of backdoor approaches because it makes everything else very inefficient. You know, a lot of people don't want rail going by them. That makes complete sense, right? The problem is you have this continuous tension between the needs of the individual
all kinds of different projects don't make sufficient concessions to the union or don't unionize the project or whatever. And so they've become a huge defender of this, not because of its environmental quality dimensions, but because it is a point of leverage they can use for labor standards. Now, I'm broadly speaking pro-union, but I would like to use like direct worker law to effectuate that, not have these sort of backdoor approaches because it makes everything else very inefficient. You know, a lot of people don't want rail going by them. That makes complete sense, right? The problem is you have this continuous tension between the needs of the individual|||各种不同项目中不对工会做出足够的妥协，或者不让项目工会化等等。因此，他们成为了这一法案的坚定捍卫者，不是因为它的环境质量维度，而是因为它是一个他们可以用来争取劳工标准的杠杆点。现在，广义上讲我是支持工会的，但我希望利用类似直接的劳工法来实这一点，而不是搞这些后门方法，因为这会让其他一切都变得非常低效。你知道的，很多人不希望铁路从他们家旁边经过。这完全合乎情理，对吧？问题在于，个人需求之间存在着这种持续的紧张关系……
and the needs of the community or the polity. If you're a mini storage site, which is one of the situations where this happened, and the high speed rail needs to move past you. And so the idea is like, can you move backwards a bit? Or can the government come and use that mini domain to take your land and compensate you? Of course you don't wanna be inconvenienced in that way. a bit, or can the government come and use that domain to take your land and compensate you?
and the needs of the community or the polity. If you're a mini storage site, which is one of the situations where this happened, and the high speed rail needs to move past you. And so the idea is like, can you move backwards a bit? Or can the government come and use that mini domain to take your land and compensate you? Of course you don't wanna be inconvenienced in that way. a bit, or can the government come and use that domain to take your land and compensate you?|||以及社区或政治实体的需求。如果你是一个迷你仓储点——这也是发生这种情况的情形之一，而高铁需要从你旁边通过。所以这个想法就像是：你能往后退一点吗？或者政府能不能来利用这个征地权（注：原文误读为mini domain，应为eminent domain）来征用你的土地并补偿你？你当然不希望以那种方式带来不便。退一点，或者政府能不能利用该土地征用权来征用你的土地并补偿你？
Of course, you don't want to be inconvenienced in that way. But on the other hand, if we can't do that, then we can't build things to go through populous areas. Other countries just deal with these questions differently. I mean, China deals with them very imperiously, but I don't think people go to Europe and think, whoa, total tyranny with no respect for individual rights. We deal with them through lawsuit. And courts take very long periods of time.
Of course, you don't want to be inconvenienced in that way. But on the other hand, if we can't do that, then we can't build things to go through populous areas. Other countries just deal with these questions differently. I mean, China deals with them very imperiously, but I don't think people go to Europe and think, whoa, total tyranny with no respect for individual rights. We deal with them through lawsuit. And courts take very long periods of time.|||当然，你不想遇到那种不便。但另一方面，如果我们做不到这一点，我们就无法修建穿过人口稠密地区的设施。其他国家处理这些问题的方式不同。我的意思是，中国以非常强势的方式处理这些问题，但我认为人们去欧洲时不会觉得：哇，这简直是毫无个人权利可言的彻底暴政。我们是通过诉讼来解决这些问题的。而法院需要很长的时间。
It's a very slow way to resolve issues. So then delay becomes like the fundamental nature of the project. I mean, we don't usually have the burden of having to believe in the law that we're sort of using on our side to make an argument. Like we do this sort of end run all the time, like using one piece of law to stop something.
It's a very slow way to resolve issues. So then delay becomes like the fundamental nature of the project. I mean, we don't usually have the burden of having to believe in the law that we're sort of using on our side to make an argument. Like we do this sort of end run all the time, like using one piece of law to stop something.|||这是一个非常缓慢的解决问题的方式。因此，拖延就成了该项目的基本属性。我的意思是，我们通常没有义务去相信我们为了论证而使用的那部分法律。就像我们一直在搞这种擦边球一样，比如利用某一条法律来阻止某事。
Isn't the point that we want to save the snail darter? We just really don't want TVA's dams or whatever it is. You know what I mean? Is that a requirement? I mean, like how would you police that or tell, you know, like... I think in the era where we built a lot of these laws, what we did, which is kind of the 70s,
Isn't the point that we want to save the snail darter? We just really don't want TVA's dams or whatever it is. You know what I mean? Is that a requirement? I mean, like how would you police that or tell, you know, like... I think in the era where we built a lot of these laws, what we did, which is kind of the 70s,|||重点难道不是我们要拯救蜗牛镖鲈吗？我们只是真的不想要田纳西流域管理局（TVA）的大坝或诸如此类的东西。你知道我的意思吗？这是一个必须的要求吗？我的意思是，你将如何监管或分辨，你知道的……我认为在我们制定许多这类法律的那个时代，我们所做的事情——大约是在70年代，
what we did was we created structures that do not internally make judgments. So something like the National Environmental Policy Act, the California Environmental Quality Act uses these as examples, but there are many, many, many others. What they demand is not that the thing you are doing is good for the environment. That's not the question the law is asking.
what we did was we created structures that do not internally make judgments. So something like the National Environmental Policy Act, the California Environmental Quality Act uses these as examples, but there are many, many, many others. What they demand is not that the thing you are doing is good for the environment. That's not the question the law is asking.|||我们所做的是创建了内部不作判断的结构。比如《国家环境政策法》、《加利福尼亚州环境质量法案》，这些只是例子，还有许许多多其他的法律。它们所要求的并不是你正在做的事情对环境有益。这并不是法律所提出的问题。
They are asking a question about how thoroughly you have researched and considered every possible impact that a court has ever defined as plausibly environmental. So there was a famous case a couple of years ago in Berkeley where a guy sued under the California Environmental Quality Act to stop Berkeley from expanding its dormitories, UC Berkeley, under the basic argument that adding more students to Berkeley was an environmental harm. They create trash, they create noise. What I would like to see is not the absence of environmental laws.
They are asking a question about how thoroughly you have researched and considered every possible impact that a court has ever defined as plausibly environmental. So there was a famous case a couple of years ago in Berkeley where a guy sued under the California Environmental Quality Act to stop Berkeley from expanding its dormitories, UC Berkeley, under the basic argument that adding more students to Berkeley was an environmental harm. They create trash, they create noise. What I would like to see is not the absence of environmental laws.|||它们所提出的问题是：你对法院曾经定义为貌似属于环境范畴的每一个可能的影响，进行了多么彻底的研究和考虑。因此，几年前在伯克利发生了一个著名的案件，有人根据《加利福尼亚州环境质量法案》提起诉讼，阻止伯克利（加州大学伯克利分校）扩建宿舍，其基本论点是：在伯克利增加更多学生是一种环境危害。他们会产生垃圾，产生噪音。我希望看到的并不是没有环境法。
I would like environmental laws where there is a judgment we are capable of making in a pretty compressed time period of whether or not a project is on net good or bad for the environment and whether it is kind of in a reasonable way thought through that question. And if it's good, then it gets sped up. And if it's bad, maybe then it requires more study. But I think the law should treat laying down an array of solar panels differently than building an oil refinery or a coal plant. And the law doesn't treat it very differently. That's a huge mistake.
I would like environmental laws where there is a judgment we are capable of making in a pretty compressed time period of whether or not a project is on net good or bad for the environment and whether it is kind of a reasonable way thought through that question. And if it's good, then it gets sped up. And if it's bad, maybe then it requires more study. But I think the law should treat laying down an array of solar panels differently than building an oil refinery or a coal plant. And the law doesn't treat it very differently. That's a huge mistake.|||我希望有这样一种环境法：我们能够在相当短的时间内做出判断，即一个项目对环境而言净收益是好是坏，以及它是否以某种合理的方式对该问题进行了深思熟虑。如果是好的，那么它就会加速推进。如果是坏的，那可能就需要更多的研究。但我认为，法律对待铺设太阳能电池板阵列的态度应该与建造炼油厂或燃煤电厂有所不同。而法律并没有对它们区别对待。这是一个巨大的错误。
I mean, this does seem like a huge cultural thing related to the United States as a very particular and unique object. You know, the closest analog that I see from history in terms of a time of abundance and state capacity is the New Deal, the WPA, TVA, PWA. How much does that historical antecedent conform to your vision of abundance? I think there's a lot of similarities. Now the sort of tension we're laying out in the book is a tension between that New Deal era of liberalism and a form of liberalism that arises in reaction to it that we often think of as the new left.
I mean, this does seem like a huge cultural thing related to the United States as a very particular and unique object. You know, the closest analog that I see from history in terms of a time of abundance and state capacity is the New Deal, the WPA, TVA, PWA. How much does that historical antecedent conform to your vision of abundance? I think there's a lot of similarities. Now the sort of tension we're laying out in the book is a tension between that New Deal era of liberalism and a form of liberalism that arises in reaction to it that we often think of as the new left.|||我的意思是，这确实看起来是一个巨大的文化现象，与美国作为一个非常特殊且独特的客体有关。你知道的，我在历史上看到的关于丰裕时期和国家能力的最接近的类似物是新政、公共工程署（WPA）、田纳西流域管理局（TVA）、公共工程管理局（PWA）。这一历史先例在多大程度上符合你对丰裕的愿景？我认为有很多相似之处。现在我们在书中阐述的那种张力，是新政时代的自由主义与作为对其反弹而产生的另一种自由主义（我们通常认为的新左翼）之间的张力。
And the left has a much more troubled relationship with government than it lets on. There's New Deal liberalism, you know, the liberalism of FDR and it's a liberalism of connections between the state and the unions and the corporations. And in that post-war period, it really builds at a torrid pace. In the 50s, in about 10 years, we increased America's housing stock by, if I'm remembering
And the left has a much more troubled relationship with government than it lets on. There's New Deal liberalism, you know, the liberalism of FDR and it's a liberalism of connections between the state and the unions and the corporations. And in that post-war period, it really builds at a torrid pace. In the 50s, in about 10 years, we increased America's housing stock by, if I'm remembering|||左翼与政府的关系比它表面上表现出来的要麻烦得多。有新政自由主义，你知道的，罗斯福的自由主义，这是一种国家、工会和企业之间建立联系的自由主义。在战后的那个时期，它确实以狂热的速度建设着。在50年代，大约10年里，我们把美国的住房存量增加了——如果我没记错的话……
the number right, about a quarter. Just shocking. But we do a lot of damage. We despoil the environment. We build a lot of really ugly things. The term tiki-taki comes from these same, same developments, a song about these same, same developments in Daly City, you know, just south of San Francisco.
the number right, about a quarter. Just shocking. But we do a lot of damage. We despoil the environment. We build a lot of really ugly things. The term tiki-taki comes from these same, same developments, a song about these same, same developments in Daly City, you know, just south of San Francisco.|||这个数字的话，大约四分之一。简直令人震惊。但我们造成了很大的破坏。我们掠夺了环境。我们建造了许多非常丑陋的东西。“tiki-taki”这个词就源于这些相同的发展项目，一首关于戴利城（就在旧金山南部）这些相同发展项目的歌曲，你知道的。
Little boxes on the hillside. Little boxes made of tiki-taki. Little boxes on the hillside. Little boxes all the same. There's a pink one. You really look in this period and there is this growing concern about a soullessness in the American growth machine. Lyndon Johnson gives a speech about how we used to worry about the ugly American, but
Little boxes on the hillside. Little boxes made of tiki-taki. Little boxes on the hillside. Little boxes all the same. There's a pink one. You really look in this period and there is this growing concern about a soullessness in the American growth machine. Lyndon Johnson gives a speech about how we used to worry about the ugly American, but|||山坡上的小盒子。用tiki-taki建造的小盒子。山坡上的小盒子。千篇一律的小盒子。还有一个粉红色的。你仔细审视这一时期，就会发现人们越来越担心美国增长机器中存在的灵魂缺失。林登·约翰逊发表了一场演讲，谈到我们过去担心“丑陋的美国人”，但……
now we worry about the ugly America. Today we must act to prevent an ugly America. For once the battle is lost, once our natural splendor is destroyed, it can never be recaptured. John Kenneth Galbraith, a legendary liberal economist of that era, writes this famous book called The Affluent Society and talks about these people camping and eating their food out of plastic containers amidst all this trash. Is this really what this was all buying us? And you have this rise of liberal critics of the government. And so this new left emerges, Ralph Nader on consumer safety and who helps build this
now we worry about the ugly America. Today we must act to prevent an ugly America. For once the battle is lost, once our natural splendor is destroyed, it can never be recaptured. John Kenneth Galbraith, a legendary liberal economist of that era, writes this famous book called The Affluent Society and talks about these people camping and eating their food out of plastic containers amidst all this trash. Is this really what this was all buying us? And you have this rise of liberal critics of the government. And so this new left emerges, Ralph Nader on consumer safety and who helps build this|||现在我们担心的是“丑陋的美国”。今天，我们必须采取行动防止一个丑陋的美国的出现。因为一旦这场战斗失败，一旦我们的自然壮丽被毁坏，就再也无法挽回了。约翰·肯尼斯·加尔布雷思，那个时代的传奇自由派经济学家，写了那本名为《丰裕社会》的名著，书中谈到这些人露营时在一堆垃圾中用塑料容器吃着食物。这真的是这一切为我们换来的东西吗？于是出现了对政府的自由派批评者的崛起。因此，这个新左翼诞生了，拉尔夫·内德关注消费者安全，并帮助建立起了……
huge network of organizations that what they do is sue the government. When Nader runs in 2000, he's asked, what qualifies you to be president? And he says, I don't think any human being alive has sued more government agencies than I have. Rachel Carson in Silent Spring, that's very much about how the government is mismanaging ecology. And so we then spend decades passing legislation that reflects this. And much of that legislation is amazing. I mean, this is all in an era where we are thinking about civil rights, where we are afraid of the totalitarian example of Nazi Germany and then the Soviet Union. And so there's a real rise in individualism, which I think we think of as economic, but
huge network of organizations that what they do is sue the government. When Nader runs in 2000, he's asked, what qualifies you to be president? And he says, I don't think any human being alive has sued more government agencies than I have. Rachel Carson in Silent Spring, that's very much about how the government is mismanaging ecology. And so we then spend decades passing legislation that reflects this. And much of that legislation is amazing. I mean, this is all in an era where we are thinking about civil rights, where we are afraid of the totalitarian example of Nazi Germany and then the Soviet Union. And so there's a real rise in individualism, which I think we think of as economic, but|||庞大的组织网络，他们的工作就是起诉政府。当内德在2000年参选时，有人问他，你有什么资格当总统？他说：“我认为活着的没有任何一个人起诉过的政府机构比我更多。”雷切尔·卡逊的《寂静的春天》，很大程度上就是关于政府如何管理生态不善的。于是我们接下来花了几十年时间通过反映这一点的立法。其中许多立法都令人惊叹。我的意思是，这一切都发生在一个我们正在思考民权的时代，一个我们害怕纳粹德国和后来的苏联的极权主义例子的时代。因此，个人主义确实有所抬头，我认为我们认为它是经济上的，但……
it was more than that. It was moral and spiritual. And it's very much reflected. Legislation is downstream of culture. You can listen to Jimmy Carter. You can listen to his State of the Union. And he's searing on all that the government cannot and should not do. Government cannot solve our problems.
it was more than that. It was moral and spiritual. And it's very much reflected. Legislation is downstream of culture. You can listen to Jimmy Carter. You can listen to his State of the Union. And he's searing on all that the government cannot and should not do. Government cannot solve our problems.|||它不仅于此。它是道德和精神上的。并且它得到了极大的体现。立法是文化的下游。你可以听听吉米·卡特的讲话。你可以听听他的国情咨文。他尖锐地抨击了政府不能做也绝对不该做的一切。政府无法解决我们的问题。
It can't set our goals. It cannot define our vision. Government cannot eliminate poverty or provide a bountiful economy or reduce inflation or save our cities or cure illiteracy or provide energy. And liberals begin to try to restrain the growth machine they have built to make sure it is more respectful of older ways of living. And all that is important and is needed and it's beautiful, but it just gets overgrown over time. It solves the problems of its time. I mean, we really did have these fluorescent rivers and I grew up outside LA when the smog
It can't set our goals. It cannot define our vision. Government cannot eliminate poverty or provide a bountiful economy or reduce inflation or save our cities or cure illiteracy or provide energy. And liberals begin to try to restrain the growth machine they have built to make sure it is more respectful of older ways of living. And all that is important and is needed and it's beautiful, but it just gets overgrown over time. It solves the problems of its time. I mean, we really did have these fluorescent rivers and I grew up outside LA when the smog|||它无法设定我们的目标。它无法定义我们的愿景。政府无法消除贫困、提供丰裕的经济、降低通货膨胀、拯救我们的城市、治愈文盲或提供能源。自由主义者开始试图克制他们建造的增长机器，以确保它更加尊重古老的生活方式。所有这些都是重要的、需要的并且是美好的，但随着时间的推移，它变得杂草丛生。它解决了那个时代的问题。我的意思是，我们确实有过那些散发着荧光的河流，而我在洛杉矶郊外长大时，雾霾……
would choke you. We solved these problems. And then the processes we used to solve them over decades got captured by other special interests and other corporations and other groups. And now we have new problems and we need new processes. But it's just so important to understand a lot of these problems are worse in blue states because it is in blue states, it's in liberal states where the new left was most powerful and was able to build the architecture of government that we now live under.
would choke you. We solved these problems. And then the processes we used to solve them over decades got captured by other special interests and other corporations and other groups. And now we have new problems and we need new processes. But it's just so important to understand a lot of these problems are worse in blue states because it is in blue states, it's in liberal states where the new left was most powerful and was able to build the architecture of government that we now live under.|||会让你窒息。我们解决了这些问题。然后，几十年来我们用来解决这些问题的程序被其他特殊利益集团、其他公司和其他群体所劫持。现在我们有了新的问题，我们需要新的程序。但非常重要的一点是要明白，许多这类问题在蓝色州更为严重，因为正是在蓝色州、在自由派州，新左翼最具势力，并能够构建我们目前生活于其下的政府架构。
And that solved many problems and it's now created others. I mean, institutional renewal, it faces every generation anew. So on the show last year as a project, we read The Power Broker over a year. That is a person in Robert Moses who both built things and bragged about them. Quite a lot. An incredible builder.
That solved many problems and it's now created others. I mean, institutional renewal, it faces every generation anew. So on the show last year as a project, we read The Power Broker over a year. That is a person in Robert Moses who both built things and bragged about them. Quite a lot. An incredible builder.|||这解决了许多问题，现在又制造了其他问题。我的意思是，机构更新，它是每一代人都要重新面对的。所以在去年的节目中，作为一个项目，我们花了整整一年时间阅读了《权力经纪人》（The Power Broker）。罗伯特·摩西（Robert Moses）就是这样一个人，他既建造了东西，又对此吹嘘不已。相当多。一个不可思议的建设者。
But he also bulldozed neighborhoods, especially poor and vulnerable neighborhoods. So how do you cut red tape so that those things can be built without an authoritarian in the style of Robert Moses who can sort of run unchecked for 44 years? I think that the left has over learned the lesson of Robert Moses. Robert Moses was part of an era in American government, the New Deal era, and we grew a lot and sometimes wisely, sometimes very unwisely. And Moses, if he was born today, couldn't get much done at all, right? Robert Moses in this institutional architecture would have a lot of trouble building, you know,
But he also bulldozed neighborhoods, especially poor and vulnerable neighborhoods. So how do you cut red tape so that those things can be built without an authoritarian in the style of Robert Moses who can sort of run unchecked for 44 years? I think that the left has over learned the lesson of Robert Moses. Robert Moses was part of an era in American government, the New Deal era, and we grew a lot and sometimes wisely, sometimes very unwisely. And Moses, if he was born today, couldn't get much done at all, right? Robert Moses in this institutional architecture would have a lot of trouble building, you know,|||但他同时也推倒了许多社区，尤其是贫困和脆弱的社区。那么，你如何在没有罗伯特·摩西那样能够肆无忌惮地主政44年的威权主义者的情况下，砍掉繁文缛节，以便把这些东西建起来呢？我认为左翼对罗伯特·摩西的教训吸取过头了。罗伯特·摩西是美国政府某个时代（即新政时代）的一部分，我们有了很大的发展，有时是明智的，有时是非常不明智的。而摩西如果生在今天，根本什么也干不成，对吧？罗伯特·摩西在这个体制架构中，在建设……方面会有很大的麻烦，你知道的，
a fraction of what he was able to build. If what you have done is build your system to try to make it impossible for bad people to act, then you've also built a system which is gonna very likely be very hard for good people to act. Now, I think you can have discernment about things. I don't think we should treat
a fraction of what he was able to build. If what you have done is build your system to try to make it impossible for bad people to act, then you've also built a system which is gonna very likely be very hard for good people to act. Now, I think you can have discernment about things. I don't think we should treat|||他当年建造的东西只是冰山一角。如果你所做的一切是建立你的系统，试图让坏人无法行动，那么你也建立了一个很可能会让好人也非常难以行动的系统。现在，我认为你可以对事物有所甄别。我不认为我们应该对待……
all building, all construction completely equally. But I do believe in the government's ability to act. I am a liberal and I think that requires electing good people. I don't think that there, and we're seeing this right now, I don't think that there is a substitute for electing people who can be trusted with public power. But I think if you make it so even the good people cannot effectively use public power in the public's interest, then eventually they're going to turn to bad people who say, as the strong man does, I alone can fix it.
all building, all construction completely equally. But I do believe in the government's ability to act. I am a liberal and I think that requires electing good people. I don't think that there, and we're seeing this right now, I don't think that there is a substitute for electing people who can be trusted with public power. But I think if you make it so even the good people cannot effectively use public power in the public's interest, then eventually they're going to turn to bad people who say, as the strong man does, I alone can fix it.|||所有的建造、所有的施工都完全一视同仁。但我确实相信政府的行动能力。我是一个自由主义者，我认为这需要选举好人。我不认为——我们现在也看到了这一点——我不认为选举那些可以被信赖掌握公共权力的人有什么替代品。但我认为，如果你把事情搞到连好人都无法有效地利用公共权力来谋取公众利益的地步，那么最终他们将会转向那些坏人，正如强人所说的那样：“只有我能解决问题。”
I'm going to ignore these laws, ignore these rules, ignore this tape. So yeah, I think there's something slightly crazy about being so afraid of a bad person acting consequentially that even in very blue states where we've learned a lot in the past, you know, however many decades, we've made it so difficult for good people to act consequentially. In the 20th century sort of growth and abundance of building things, one of the things that happened was we often asked the same people to bear the cost of our collective desires. People who lived in poorer communities were bulldozed. How do you stop that from happening of having the same people always bear the cost of what we want to do collectively?
I'm going to ignore these laws, ignore these rules, ignore this tape. So yeah, I think there's something slightly crazy about being so afraid of a bad person acting consequentially that even in very blue states where we've learned a lot in the past, you know, however many decades, we've made it so difficult for good people to act consequentially. In the 20th century sort of growth and abundance of building things, one of the things that happened was we often asked the same people to bear the cost of our collective desires. People who lived in poorer communities were bulldozed. How do you stop that from happening of having the same people always bear the cost of what we want to do collectively?|||我要无视这些法律，无视这些规则，无视这些繁文缛节。所以，是的，我认为过度害怕一个坏人会产生重大影响，以至于甚至在过去几十年里我们学到了很多的深蓝州，我们都把好人采取有意义的行动变得如此困难，这有点疯狂。在20世纪那种增长和建设丰裕的时期，发生的事情之一就是我们经常要求同一群人来承担我们集体欲望的代价。住在较贫困社区的人们的房屋被推土机推平了。你如何阻止这种情况发生，即总是让同一群人来承担我们想要集体做的事情的代价？
So I want to note two things here because I do think it's really important to say those people also bear the cost of things not getting built. If we do not transition away from fossil fuel energy, it is going to be worst on the poor, not the rich. When we didn't build California high speed rail, that was worse for the poor than the rich, right? That the consequences of not delivering, it falls heavily on those communities too. I just always think it's a very, very important point because we often recognize the costs of action, but not the costs of inaction. Agreed.
So I want to note two things here because I do think it's really important to say those people also bear the cost of things not getting built. If we do not transition away from fossil fuel energy, it is going to be worst on the poor, not the rich. When we didn't build California high speed rail, that was worse for the poor than the rich, right? That the consequences of not delivering, it falls heavily on those communities too. I just always think it's a very, very important point because we often recognize the costs of action, but not the costs of inaction. Agreed.|||所以我在这里想指出两点，因为我真的觉得非常重要的一点是，那些人也承担了事情没有建成的代价。如果我们不从化石燃料能源转型，受害最深的将是穷人，而不是富人。当我们没有修建加州高铁时，这对穷人的伤害比对富人的伤害更大，对吧？未能兑现承诺的后果，也沉重地落在了那些社区身上。我总是认为这是一个非常非常重要的点，因为我们往往能看到采取行动的代价，却看不到不作为的代价。同意。
But then I think there's actually a lot of ways you could approach this if you wanted to. So you could, let's take housing as an example. The reality is that rich communities have political power and use procedural mechanisms, and they make it very hard to up zone in those communities. And so big apartment buildings and density happens where people are poor. hard to up zone in those communities. And so big apartment buildings and density happens
But then I think there's actually a lot of ways you could approach this if you wanted to. So you could, let's take housing as an example. The reality is that rich communities have political power and use procedural mechanisms, and they make it very hard to up zone in those communities. And so big apartment buildings and density happens where people are poor. hard to up zone in those communities. And so big apartment buildings and density happens|||但随后我认为，如果你愿意的话，实际上有很多方法可以解决这个问题。所以你可以——让我们以住房为例。现实情况是，富裕社区拥有政治权力并使用程序机制，他们使得在这些社区提高土地容积率（upzone）变得极其困难。因此，大型公寓楼和高密度建设往往发生在人们贫困的地方。在这些社区提高容积率变得极其困难。因此，大型公寓楼和高密度建设往往发生……
where people are poor. In some like conceptual way, if you removed a lot of zoning laws and rules, of course developers would wanna build in rich areas. And so having created all these procedural veto points, you've given every rich community in the country who's got the money to hire lawyers and lobbyists, a lot of ways to stop things from being built. And asymmetrically, poor communities don't
where people are poor. In some like conceptual way, if you removed a lot of zoning laws and rules, of course developers would wanna build in rich areas. And so having created all these procedural veto points, you've given every rich community in the country who's got the money to hire lawyers and lobbyists, a lot of ways to stop things from being built. And asymmetrically, poor communities don't|||在人们贫困的地方。从某种概念上讲，如果你取消了很多分区法律和规则，开发商当然会想在富裕地区建造。因此，在创造了所有这些程序性否决点之后，你为全国每一个有钱雇佣律师和游说者的富裕社区提供了大量的途径来阻止项目的建设。而不对等地，贫困社区却没有……
have all that. Recognizing the process is often a tool that is of differential use, depending on the resources you have to activate that tool, is I think a very, very important part of like taking, you know, the costs of over regulating the government seriously. And then yet you have to elect people. There's no way to get away from this. You have to elect people with a just vision of the future. If you don't, it's going to go badly. It's going to go badly through inaction, through action. But you have to, you actually have to elect people who take seriously that we don't want to, as said by George W. Bush, balance a budget on the backs of the poor. You want to elect people who take distribution seriously
have all that. Recognizing the process is often a tool that is of differential use, depending on the resources you have to activate that tool, is I think a very, very important part of like taking, you know, the costs of over regulating the government seriously. And then yet you have to elect people. There's no way to get away from this. You have to elect people with a just vision of the future. If you don't, it's going to go badly. It's going to go badly through inaction, through action. But you have to, you actually have to elect people who take seriously that we don't want to, as said by George W. Bush, balance a budget on the backs of the poor. You want to elect people who take distribution seriously|||这一切。认识到程序通常是一个具有差异化效用的工具——这取决于你拥有哪些资源来激活该工具——我认为这是严肃看待过度监管政府的代价的一个非常非常重要的部分。然而，你还是必须选举人员。这是无法逃避的。你必须选举具有对未来的公正愿景的人。如果不这样，事情就会变糟。无论是因为不作为还是因为采取行动，事情都会变糟。但你必须、你实际上必须选举那些认真对待以下观点的人：正如乔治·W·布什所说，我们不希望以牺牲穷人为代价来平衡预算。你想选举那些认真对待分配的人……
and then can do something to effectuate that. It really is about judgment over process. I mean, cause that's one of the reasons why it's so difficult to talk about this in the broad sense is that the case by case of what is a good product versus what is a bad product is very specific, you know? And so it really requires individual judgment. And we seem to have legislated our way out of individual judgment. I often say that what I want to do is make it possible for the government to act
and then can do something to effectuate that. It really is about judgment over process. I mean, cause that's one of the reasons why it's so difficult to talk about this in the broad sense is that the case by case of what is a good product versus what is a bad product is very specific, you know? And so it really requires individual judgment. And we seem to have legislated our way out of individual judgment. I often say that what I want to do is make it possible for the government to act|||然后能够做点什么来使之生效。这确实是关于判断力而非程序的问题。我的意思是，这也是为什么在宏观意义上讨论这个问题如此困难的原因之一，因为什么是好产品与什么是坏产品的个案情况是非常具体的，你知道吗？因此它确实需要个人的判断力。而我们似乎已经通过立法消灭了个人的判断力。我经常说，我想做的是让政府有可能采取行动……
with some level of trust. And the way we do it now, we, you know, and this is a very American thing, we just don't trust the government. And look, I don't trust the Trump administration. But also, I think the Trump administration is partially a response to government that's become unbelievably sclerotic
with some level of trust. And the way we do it now, we, you know, and this is a very American thing, we just don't trust the government. And look, I don't trust the Trump administration. But also, I think the Trump administration is partially a response to government that's become unbelievably sclerotic|||并带有一定程度的信任。而我们现在做事的方式，我们——你知道的，这是一件非常美国化的事情——我们就是不信任政府。听着，我不信任特朗普政府。但同时，我认为特朗普政府在某种程度上是对变得难以置信地僵化的政府的一种回应。
and unresponsive over time. Because again, we don't imbue it with any trust. So we make it, again, in normal times before Doe's started breaking the law left and right, we get very hard to hire and fire civil servants. And we make it very hard for the same civil servants to manage and to act. They are in wrapped in unbelievably complex levels of process and auditing and oversight
and unresponsive over time. Because again, we don't imbue it with any trust. So we make it, again, in normal times before Doe's started breaking the law left and right, we get very hard to hire and fire civil servants. And we make it very hard for the same civil servants to manage and to act. They are in wrapped in unbelievably complex levels of process and auditing and oversight|||并且随着时间推移变得毫无反应的政府。因为同样地，我们没有赋予它任何信任。所以我们让它——再说一次，在“多伊”（Doe，泛指）开始左右逢源地违法之前的正常时期，我们很难雇用和解雇公务员。并且我们让这些公务员极难进行管理和采取行动。他们被包裹在令人难以置信的复杂层级的程序、审计和监督之中。
to make sure they never, you know, quote unquote, waste any money. Meanwhile, all this auditing and oversight is itself wasting huge amounts of money. And I mean, the difference between how we run government and how Europe often runs government is not that we have a liberal democracy and they don't. It's that in Europe, you know, not a hundred percent, but much more so than here, the judgments are made by the civil servants and they have a base on level of trust and quality of the bureaucracy. And here, because we don't, we do it by lawsuit.
to make sure they never, you know, quote unquote, waste any money. Meanwhile, all this auditing and oversight is itself wasting huge amounts of money. And I mean, the difference between how we run government and how Europe often runs government is not that we have a liberal democracy and they don't. It's that in Europe, you know, not a hundred percent, but much more so than here, the judgments are made by the civil servants and they have a base on level of trust and quality of the bureaucracy. And here, because we don't, we do it by lawsuit.|||以确保他们绝不，你知道的，所谓“浪费”任何金钱。与此同时，所有这些审计和监督本身就在浪费巨额资金。我的意思是，我们运营政府的方式与欧洲通常运营政府的方式之间的区别，并不是我们拥有自由民主而他们没有。而是在欧洲，你知道的，虽说不是百分之百，但比这里要多得多，决策是由公务员做出的，他们对官僚机构拥有基本的信任和质量水平。而在我们这里，因为我们没有这样做，我们通过诉讼来解决。
And it's not a hundred percent clear to me why we would think that a judge is better at adjudicating an environmental dispute than the Environmental Protection Agency and its actual environmental experts would be. But that's how we do it. And having removed all this discretion from the political system, we've instead imbued it in process. And what the political system has to prove over and over and over again to the courts is that they have followed the process to the letter, to the T. And over time that process becomes more and more complex.
And it's not a hundred percent clear to me why we would think that a judge is better at adjudicating an environmental dispute than the Environmental Protection Agency and its actual environmental experts would be. But that's how we do it. And having removed all this discretion from the political system, we've instead imbued it in process. And what the political system has to prove over and over and over again to the courts is that they have followed the process to the letter, to the T. And over time that process becomes more and more complex.|||我并不是百分之百清楚，为什么我们会认为法官在裁决环境争端时会比环境保护局及其真正的环境专家做得更好。但我们就是这么做的。在剥夺了政治系统的所有这些自由裁量权之后，我们转而将其注入到了程序之中。政治系统必须一次又一次、一遍又一遍地向法院证明的是，他们严格、不折不扣地遵循了程序。随着时间的推移，这个程序变得越来越复杂。
I mean, very famously environmental reviews used to be like seven pages, a dozen pages, and now there are thousands of pages and take three and a half or four and a half years. But that unwillingness to trust the people we elect is very profound. When we come back, Ezra Klein says we need new processes to solve new problems. That's a hit. We are back with Ezra Klein, co-author of Abundance. The book has been getting a lot of attention in urbanism and policy circles, and some people
I mean, very famously environmental reviews used to be like seven pages, a dozen pages, and now there are thousands of pages and take three and a half or four and a half years. But that unwillingness to trust the people we elect is very profound. When we come back, Ezra Klein says we need new processes to solve new problems. That's a hit. We are back with Ezra Klein, co-author of Abundance. The book has been getting a lot of attention in urbanism and policy circles, and some people|||我的意思是，众所周知，环境审查过去只有七页、一打页，而现在却有数千页，需要三到四年半的时间。但这种不愿意信任我们选举出来的人的心理是非常根深蒂固的。广告回来后，埃兹拉·克莱因说我们需要新的程序来解决新的问题。这很中肯。欢迎回来，我们请到了《丰裕》的合著者埃兹拉·克莱因。这本书在城市规划和政策圈引起了极大的关注，有些人……
have been critical, saying that it seems like abundance is arguing for massive deregulation. But we as a society have benefited a lot from different regulations. Like in LA, near where Ezra grew up, smog used to be a huge issue, but we solved it with regulation. I asked Ezra if he worried that issues that we solved, like smog, could be unsolved. No, I don't actually on that specific one. What I really worry is that LA is going to be cooked if we don't build enough green energy. Again, you have to align your processes to your problems. We are not in Los Angeles, in Phoenix, facing the major problem of smog.
have been critical, saying that, it seems like abundance is arguing for massive deregulation. But we as a society have benefited a lot from different regulations. Like in LA, near where Ezra grew up, smog used to be a huge issue, but we solved it with regulation. I asked Ezra if he worried that issues that we solved, like smog, could be unsolved. No, I don't actually on that specific one. What I really worry is that LA is going to be cooked if we don't build enough green energy. Again, you have to align your processes to your problems. We are not in Los Angeles, in Phoenix, facing the major problem of smog.|||一直在批评，称《丰裕》似乎在主张大规模放松管制。但我们作为社会，从不同的法规中受益匪浅。比如在埃兹拉长大的洛杉矶附近，雾霾曾经是个大问题，但我们通过监管解决了它。我问埃兹拉，他是否担心像雾霾这样我们已经解决的问题会重新出现。不，针对具体的那一个，我其实并不担心。我真正担心的是，如果我们不建设足够的绿色能源，洛杉矶就要完蛋了。再说一次，你必须让你的程序与你的问题相契合。我们在洛杉矶、在菲尼克斯，面临的主要问题已经不是雾霾。
We are facing the major problem of climate change. And if the answer to climate change was make it hard to build stuff, well, great, then we have the answer. But the answer to climate change, at least the one we've chosen as a society, is you got to build a huge amount of wind turbines and solar panels and transmission lines and electric vehicle charges. And if we don't do that, we're going to have all the problems that we know are coming. I mean, in LA, like the reason you can't breathe in LA for much of the year is wildfires that are made worse by extreme weather conditions.
We are facing the major problem of climate change. And if the answer to climate change was make it hard to build stuff, well, great, then we have the answer. But the answer to climate change, at least the one we've chosen as a society, is you got to build a huge amount of wind turbines and solar panels and transmission lines and electric vehicle charges. And if we don't do that, we're having all the problems that we know are coming. I mean, in LA, like the reason you can't breathe in LA for much of the year is wildfires that are made worse by extreme weather conditions.|||我们正面临着气候变化这一重大问题。如果应对气候变化的答案是“让建造东西变得困难”，那太好了，那我们就有答案了。但应对气候变化的答案——至少是我们作为一个社会所选择的答案是：你必须建造大量的风力涡轮机、太阳能电池板、输电线路和电动汽车充电桩。如果我们不这样做，我们就会遇到我们深知即将来临的所有问题。我的意思是，在洛杉矶，比如你在一年中的大部分时间里在洛杉矶无法呼吸的原因，是由极端天气条件恶化的野火造成的。
Now occur year after year after year, Phoenix gets to temperatures that are inhuman. Yeah. So we know what our problems are. Yes, if we solve those problems, we might've built processes that in another 30 or 40 years become somebody else's problem. Good, like that's the cycle here.
Now occur year after year after year, Phoenix gets to temperatures that are inhuman. Yeah. So we know what our problems are. Yes, if we solve those problems, we might've built processes that in another 30 or 40 years become somebody else's problem. Good, like that's the cycle here.|||现在年复一年地发生，菲尼克斯的气温达到了不属于人类生存的高温。是的。所以我们知道我们的问题是什么。是的，如果我们解决了这些问题，我们可能建立了一些程序，在另外30或40年后变成了别人的问题。很好，这就像这里的循环一样。
There's no- It means we're alive in 30 years. There's no end point of history, right? May we be so successful that someone else has to unwind what we've done as opposed to they look back and think, oh my God, if only they'd done something. I'm really intrigued by this in the context of climate change because it requires a lot of building, a lot of rethinking things.
There's no- It means we're alive in 30 years. There's no end point of history, right? May we be so successful that someone else has to unwind what we've done as opposed to they look back and think, oh my God, if only they'd done something. I'm really intrigued by this in the context of climate change because it requires a lot of building, a lot of rethinking things.|||没有——这意味着我们在30年后还活着。历史没有终点，对吧？愿我们取得如此巨大的成功，以至于别人不得不解开我们所做的事情，而不是他们回首往事时想：天哪，要是他们当年做点什么就好了。在气候变化的背景下，我对这一点非常感兴趣，因为它需要大量的建设，需要对许多事情进行重新思考。
And that is exactly what we are not poised to do right now, especially with the headwinds of a lot of people not thinking that that's a problem at all to be fixed. How do you navigate that? I think that you have to split the problem of opposition to what you want to do from inability to do what in theory you have the power to do. So yes, if you lose the election to Donald Trump, the reason your climate change agenda is not going to move forward is that you lost the election to Donald Trump. The reason your climate change agenda is not going to move forward is that you lost the election to Donald Trump. But if you're Joe Biden
And that is exactly what we are not poised to do right now, especially with the headwinds of a lot of people not thinking that that's a problem at all to be fixed. How do you navigate that? I think that you have to split the problem of opposition to what you want to do from inability to do what in theory you have the power to do. So yes, if you lose the election to Donald Trump, the reason your climate change agenda is not going to move forward is that you lost the election to Donald Trump. The reason your climate change agenda is not going to move forward is that you lost the election to Donald Trump. But if you're Joe Biden|||而这正是我们目前没有准备好去做的，特别是伴随着许多人根本认为这不是一个需要解决的问题的逆风。你如何应对这种情况？我认为，你必须把“对你想要做的事情的反对”这个问题，与“无法做到你理论上有权做到的事情”区分开来。所以是的，如果你在选举中输给了唐纳德·特朗普，你的气候会议（气候变化议程）无法推进的原因就是你输给了唐纳德·特朗普。你的气候变化议程无法推进的原因是你输给了唐纳德·特朗普。但如果你是乔·拜登……
and you have a Democratic Congress, that's not the problem for you actually. The problem for you is that you didn't do permitting reform. And so you can't build as much as you need to build. Now, they have done a lot of building of, you know, solar panel, right? I don't want to take the Inflation Reduction Act is a very, very important piece of legislation,
and you have a Democratic Congress, that's not the problem for you actually. The problem for you is that you didn't do permitting reform. And so you can't build as much as you need to build. Now, they have done a lot of building of, you know, solar panel, right? I don't want to take the Inflation Reduction Act is a very, very important piece of legislation,|||并且你拥有一个民主党掌控的国会，对你而言，那其实并不是问题。对你而言的问题是，你没有进行许可改革。因此你无法建造你需要建造的那么多东西。现在，他们确实建造了大量的，你知道的，太阳能电池板，对吧？我不想认为《削减通胀法案》是一项非常非常重要的立法，……
but everybody involved in it knew that to achieve what it needed to achieve, we needed to make it possible to build things that we cannot build at speed right now. Transmission lines being a, again, a very good example. And so I, one reason I wrote a book that's very focused on the pathologies of democratic governance is that I actually think oftentimes if you're a liberal and I'm a liberal, the problems of the Republican Party, the challenges it poses, the things it believes, they're such an obvious problem for you that they're a way of not looking at what you're doing or not doing. But I don't have an answer for how you make the Republican Party believe in climate change.
但其中涉及的每个人都知道，为了实现我们需要达到的目标，我们必须能够以目前无法企及的速度建造东西。输电线路就是一个很好的例子。因此，我之所以写一本高度关注民主治理病理的书，是因为我实际上认为，通常情况下，如果你是个自由派，而我也是个自由派，共和党的问题、它带来的挑战、它的信仰，对你来说都是显而易见的问题，以至于它们成了你逃避审视自己行为的借口。但我不知道如何让共和党相信气候变化。
I don't think any liberal does. What I have an answer for is how when Democrats win power, they can actually deliver. And by the way, I think if they actually did deliver, it is less likely Republicans would win so much power. If Kamala Harris could have run around the country saying, look, look at this gleaming nationwide network of electric vehicle charges that anybody can use now for free. Look at how we expanded rural broadband to 40 million people who needed it. Look at all of these roads we built you. Look at how the bridge near you has been repaired. Right? We said we were going to build, look around, look how much we built,
我想没有哪个自由派知道。我知道的是，当民主党人赢得权力时，他们如何能够真正兑现承诺。顺便说一句，我认为如果他们真的兑现了承诺，共和党就不大可能赢得那么大的权力。如果卡马拉·哈里斯能在全国到处跑，说，看，看看这个闪闪发光的全国性电动汽车充电网络，现在任何人都可以免费使用。看看我们是如何将农村宽带扩展到4000万需要它的民众。看看我们为你们修建的所有这些道路。看看你附近的桥梁是如何修缮的。对不对？我们说过我们要建设，环顾四周，看看我们建设了多少，
but she couldn't. And like, I've done a lot of interviews with Biden people. I mean, they say it's like, it's a problem that what they had to brag about were passage of bills, not things in the real world that people could look at and feel. It's very, very hard to tell a story about legislation as opposed to a story about the way your life is actively different right now. I'm not saying that delivering through policy is enough to win every election. I don't believe that it is. But it helps.
但她做不到。而且，我采访了很多拜登团队的人。我的意思是，他们说这就像是一个问题，他们不得不吹嘘的是法案的通过，而不是人们在现实世界中能看到和感受到的东西。讲一个关于立法的故事，要比讲一个你的生活现在正发生积极改变的故事难得多、难得多。我不是说通过政策兑现承诺就足以赢得每一次选举。我不认为如此。但它有帮助。
It's better than not delivering the policy you promised. I think one of the problems we have is that we've reduced the government sort of direct interaction with people to these small and painful moments like taxes and parking meters. And I think people feel the inconvenience of construction more than they really internally feel the pleasure and freedom of driving over a bridge. I happen to get a lot of pleasure from driving over a bridge. But like that's-
总比没有兑现你承诺的政策要好。我认为我们遇到的问题之一，是我们将政府与人们的直接互动简化成了那些微小而痛苦的时刻，比如税收和停车计时器。而且我认为，人们对施工带来的不便的感受，远胜于他们内心里对开车驶过一座桥梁的快乐和自由的感受。我恰好从开车过桥中获得很多乐趣。但那就像——
I imagine you're a mindful bridge driver. But you know what I'm saying? Like we've reduced ourselves to such an extent that, you know, like, you know, it could be through just like, there just was like this thing took over, I think I blame Reagan. And then the follow on Democrats following Reagan sort of took this as just like, we want government to be so small and
我想你是一个懂得享受的司机。但你知道我的意思吗？我们把自己的职能削减到了这种程度，以至于，你知道的，就好像是某种东西接管了一切，我想我得怪里根。然后里根之后的民主党人也顺理成章地认为，我们希望政府小而
obtrusive and that just made it so that we reduced our interaction with government to these little painful moments that are not very good for the PR of the government. I think you're right to bring up Reagan here because it's a couple things about that. One is it, I don't think it's true exactly that people only interface with government in those moments. I mean, they get Medicare, they get social security, they get Medicaid, the Affordable Care Act. There is a lot that happens that is government, as you mentioned, roads and bridges.
不干预，这使得我们与政府的互动缩减到了这些痛苦的小时刻，这对政府的公关非常不利。我认为你在这里提到了里根是很中肯的，因为其中有几点。其一是，人们只在这些时刻与政府打交道，我觉得这并不完全真实。我的意思是，他们获得了联邦医疗保险（Medicare）、社会保障、医疗补助（Medicaid）、平价医疗法案。正如你所提到的，道路和桥梁，有许多事情都是政府在做的。
But the rhetorical attack on government was so successful that it's first a very hard narrative to dislodge. Elon Musk was retweeting something I was saying to Jon Stewart. It's like, see, they're gonna make everything in the government like the DMV. Democrats make everything in the government like the DMV. I would say that my last set of experiences
但针对政府的言论攻击是如此成功，以至于这首先是一个很难消除的叙事。埃隆·马斯克曾转发过我对乔·斯图尔特说的一段话。这就好比，看吧，他们要把政府里的所有东西都弄得像车管所（DMV）一样。民主党人把政府里的所有东西都弄得像车管所一样。我想说，我最近几次跟
with the DMV have been pretty good, actually. Now, maybe that's not true for everybody, but my understanding is actually true for a lot of people. But it's so counter-narrative that it's almost like hard to talk about it. And then the other just reality is we're not running government well. Look, California is a big rich state. It should run the government in a way
车管所打交道的经历其实都相当不错。现在，也许这并不适合所有人，但据我了解，对许多人来说确实如此。但这完全违背了主流叙事，以至于几乎很难谈论它。另一个现实是，我们没有把政府管理好。听着，加州是一个富裕的大州。它应该以这样一种方式管理政府：
where people from California, politicians from California should be able to go all around the country and say, look, if you vote for us, we're gonna make everything like California. But California is failing in a bunch of different ways. Not every way, I mean, it's the, you know, leads technology in the world and culture creation and it's wealthy, but it's homelessness problem is terrible.
来自加州的加州人、加州政治家应该能够走到全国各地说，看，如果你投票给我们，我们会把一切都变得像加州一样。但加州在许多不同的方面都在失败。并非所有方面，我的意思是，它是，你知道的，在世界技术和文化创造方面处于领先地位，而且它很富有，但它的无家可归者问题太严重了。
The difficulty in building there is really profound. And so there's been a right-wing attack on government, a sland attack on government, a slandering of government, and then a kind of liberal hobbling of government. What there has not been is a both aggressive effort to expand state capacity to make the government really work, and then to sell that expansion of state capacity.
在那里建造东西的难度确实非常巨大。因此，一直存在着对政府的右翼攻击、对政府的诬陷、对政府的诽谤，然后是一种自由派对政府的束缚。没有发生的是，一方面没有采取积极努力来扩大国家能力以真正让政府运转起来，另一方面也没有去兜售这种国家能力扩张的成果。
Look, we did this and you get this now. This is, I would say broadly speaking, another problem Democrats have is that they just don't, you know, there's a kind of genius to Donald Trump minutes after he was sworn in really, going and signing executive orders in public, like he was gonna pull out a t-shirt cannon, you know, and fire MAGA t-shirts into the crowd.
瞧，我们做了这个，现在你得到了这个。我想说，广泛而言，民主党人面临的另一个问题是，他们就是不——你知道的，唐纳德·特朗普在他宣誓就职后几分钟内就有一种天才般的举动，公开签署行政命令，就像他要掏出一门T恤大农炮一样，你知道的，把MAGA T恤射向人群。
Democrats, they do everything through process. They do it very carefully. Like, build some things that are monuments to government efficiency. Choose some projects that are headline projects for you, and then build the rules around them so you get them done and you get them done fast and then brag about them, brag about them everywhere.
民主党人，他们通过程序做所有事情。他们做得非常小心。比如，建造一些作为政府效率丰碑的东西；为你自己选择一些头条项目，然后围绕它们建立规则，以便你完成它们，并且快速完成它们，然后吹嘘它们，在任何地方吹嘘它们。
Like make them into an advertisement for what it is you're doing. You know, Joe Biden has said that one of his big regrets is that unlike Donald Trump, when he was sending out early stimulus checks, he didn't put his face and name and you know, he wouldn't make them advertisements for himself. name and you know, he wouldn't make him advertisements for himself. He, you know, he was being, what's he even the word prudent? That's not quite the right word. He was humble. He thought it was uncouth. Yeah. I would like to see some people who are a little bit uncouth about government in a positive way, not a
就像把它们变成你正在做的事情的广告一样。你知道，乔·*登曾说过，他最大的遗憾之一是，不像唐纳德·特朗普在发放早期的经济刺激支票时，没有把自己的脸和名字放上去，你知道的，他不会把它们变成自己的广告。名字和名字，你知道的，他不会把它们变成自己的广告。他，你知道的，表现得很，这个词怎么说来，谨慎？这不太对。他很谦逊。他认为这很不体面。是的。我希望看到一些人在对待政府时有点不那么正统、有点积极意义上的“不体面”，而不是
negative way, right? Who, who, who are out there sending the signal that this is so good and so something you can trust. But you got to deliver then. You're not going to be able to do that to top the disaster of high-speed rail or the Boston Big Dig or the New York Second Avenue subway. So in the book, you do have a couple thought exercises of sort of a sci-fi world of abundance that is imaginable. But I wonder if you could expand on that to envision a world in which things can get built, but voices get heard. What is the mechanism?
消极的，对吧？他们走出去，发出这样的信号：这太棒了，这是你可以信赖的东西。但随后你必须兑现承诺。你不可能用它来掩盖高速铁路、波士顿“大挖洞”（Big Dig）或纽约第二大道地铁灾难。所以在书中，你可以看到一些关于可以想象的丰裕科幻世界的思想实验。但我想知道你是否可以就此展开，去构想一个能够建造东西同时又能听到各种声音的世界。机制是什么？
If this didn't work, if like endless city council meetings and endless lawsuits didn't work, what is the version of this that does work? I mean, on any given area we're talking about, I can just point you to a place where it's working fine now. Austin is full of liberals. Is the way housing is done in Austin, is that truly so fascist? Do the people living in Austin under that
如果这不管用，如果无休止的市议会会议和无休止的诉讼不管用，那么什么版本的做法才管用呢？我的意思是，在我们讨论的任何特定领域，我都可以直接指出一个现在运转良好的地方。奥斯汀充满了自由派。奥斯汀的住房建设方式，真的那么法西斯吗？生活在奥斯汀、处于这种
regime of being able to build apartments when people move there, do they truly experience it as such an endless abrogation of their rights? Is when people go to Spain or France and they ride the trains there, does it really seem so brutal? I mean, what I'm really saying is that there are other places where you've simply struck the balance better. And I think if you go to those places, they're perfectly happy. And we just build public infrastructure
当人们搬来时能够建造公寓的体制下的人们，真的将之体验为对其权利无休止的剥夺吗？当人们去西班牙或法国并乘坐那里的火车时，真的觉得那么残酷吗？我的意思是，我真正要说的是，在其他地方，你只是把平衡点把握得更好。我想如果你去那些地方，他们会过得非常开心。而我们只是以一种
in a costly, ineffective way. And we could learn things from Japan and from much of Europe. And so I sell this because I don't want to make it into sci-fi, this part. I actually want to say that we are familiar with better examples and we should learn from them. So you've been out in the country talking to all kinds of people, big audiences and podcasts and all kinds of things on this book tour. What is the hardest question that you've had to answer for?
昂贵且低效的方式建设公共基础设施。我们可以从日本和欧洲大部分地区吸取经验。所以我这样说并不是为了把这部分内容变成科幻小说。我实际上是想说，我们对更好的例子并不陌生，我们应该向他们学习。所以你在全国各地奔波，在这个新书巡回宣传中与各种各样的人交谈，面对庞大的观众、播客以及各种事物。你不得不回答的最难的问题是什么？
And if you could quickly put out the paperback dish and not that there's something wrong, but more just like, oh, if I just would have put this in, I would have gotten this question less maybe. What is the thing that you would like to present and change that you think is worth talking about? It's been, I wonder if I'm satisfying my answer will be here. We should have put more in the book about financing and cost of construction, which is just, it's a big, look, there's, the book is operating at different levels and the pushback
如果你能快点推出平装版——倒不是说有什么问题，而是更像是，“哦，如果我把这个写进去，我可能会少被问到这个问题”。你希望展示和改变的是什么，你认为这是值得讨论的？这一直是，我在想我的回答是否会在这里。我们本应该在书中加入更多关于融资和建设成本的内容，这简直是，这是一个大问题，听着，这本书在不同的层面上运作，而反弹
comes at different levels. And some of the pushback is political, but I think not in a way that I can, you know, drain it. Like people are just going to want politics to be about different things that I want it to be about, right? I think that's totally reasonable. So that pushback hasn't really bothered me. The pushback that does bother me a bit is when I go places and say, well, look, we actually
也来自不同的层面。有些反弹是政治性的，但我认为这并不是我无法应对的。就像人们只是希望政治关心的事物与我希望它关心的事物不同，对吧？我认为这完全合理。所以这种反弹并没有真正困扰我。确实有点困扰我的反弹是，当我走到一些地方说，好吧，看，我们实际上
have come to a regime, you know, permitting regime, more like what you're saying, but actually like none of the projects net out, we can't finance them in this interest rate environment. And then you get into very, very difficult things about how we've made it, why we've made it so expensive to construct in blue states. So I would have dug more into the economics of that. And like the literal cost of construction. So that's maybe one answer. Look, I think the question of voice is just a hard question.
已经进入了一种体制，你知道的，类似于你所说的许可体制，但实际上所有的项目都没有净收益，我们在这种利率环境下无法为它们融资。然后你就会深入探讨一些非常非常困难的问题，关于我们是如何做到这一点的，为什么我们在蓝州让建设变得如此昂贵。所以我本可以更深入地研究其中的经济学问题。比如字面上的建设成本。所以这或许是一个答案。听着，我认为关于声音（意见）的问题确实是一个难题。
Nobody knows exactly the right way to balance it out. You do want there to be places in process for people in a community, for affected groups, for those who are going to bear a heavier burden from any project to be able to make their voices heard. How do you do that in a way that is constructive? How do you do that in a way where it doesn't lend itself to endless delay, but it also doesn't lend itself to being completely ignored?
没有人确切知道如何平衡这一点。你确实希望在社区居民、受影响的群体、以及那些将从任何项目中承担更重负担的人的流程中，有能够让他们发出声音的地方。你如何以一种具有建设性的方式做到这一点？你如何做到既不导致无休止的拖延，又不会完全被忽视？
That's a very, very, very hard design issue. And it'll be different in, you know, I mean, what you need to think about for the lying down of interstate transmission lines is different than what you need to think about for, you know, building an apartment building in Minneapolis But you do like voice is an important part of democratic politics I think we've confused it with delay and
这是一个非常、非常、非常困难的设计问题。而且它会因情况而不同，我的意思是，你需要为铺设跨州输电线路考虑的事情，与你需要为（你知道的）在明尼阿波利斯建造公寓楼考虑的事情是不同的。但你确实——声音（公众意见）是民主政治的重要组成部分。我认为我们把它与拖延混淆了，还有
Veto yeah, but healthy levels of voice are you know? That's something that I thought a lot about in the book I just don't have the problem is I just don't have one answer for it It's a it's one of many things will have to be balanced. I think that's right. I mean, these are so specific. I mean, zoning isn't a federal issue. These are all cities who do zoning loss. I mean, they do them differently. And they do them very differently in very different places. I mean, and you mentioned the fact that, you know, Texas can build a lot of solar panel and wind farms,
否决权。是的，但是健康的民意表达是，你知道的？这是我在书中思考了很久的事情。我只是没有——问题是我对此没有一个答案。这是必须平衡的诸多事情之一。我认为这很对。我的意思是，这些都非常具体。我的意思是，分区规划（Zoning）不是一个联邦问题。这些都是制定分区法的城市。我的意思是，他们的做法不同。而且他们在不同的地方做得非常不同。我的意思是，你提到了这样一个事实，即（你知道的）德克萨斯州可以建造大量的太阳能电池板和风电场，
but they also decided to cut themselves off from the national grid and that caused the death of a bunch of people freezing in the wintertime when it didn't work anymore. The details are what matters almost, you know? I have to joke that one of the terms for this politics that caught on was a liberalism that builds, but I have to say it's really a liberalism of the details. It's about the details of what happens after you pass a bill. What happens when you're trying to turn that aspiration into a lived reality. And I think people tend to check out during that part.
但他们也决定将自己与国家电网隔离开来，当它不再起作用时，这导致了一群人在冬天的寒冷中冻死。细节几乎才是最重要的，你知道吗？我不得不开玩笑说，这种政治流行起来的一个术语是“能够建设的自由主义”（a liberalism that builds），但我必须说，它其实是“细节的自由主义”。它关乎通过法案后所发生事情的细节。关乎当你试图将这种愿景变成现实生活时会发生什么。我认为人们往往会在那个阶段选择退场。
We pass the Affordable Care Act. It's done. We did it. We passed the Inficient Reduction Act. Now climate change is going to be solved. So how it works. What happens after that is really, really important. And it's often much worse than you would think because it happens in more in the shadows.
我们通过了《平价医疗法案》。事情完成了。我们做到了。我们通过了《削减通胀法案》。现在气候变化问题将得到解决。它是如何运作的。在那之后发生的事情真的非常非常重要。而且它通常比你想象的要糟糕得多，因为它更多地发生在暗处。
It happens with processes that as well intentioned as they may have been or are easy for corporations to capture, easy for special interests to capture, easy for incumbent homeowners to capture. They're easy for the people who know them and have the money to participate in them to capture. And so, you know, being very attentive to did the thing you passed work out the way you wanted it to and then going back and revisiting it if it didn't. You know, I would, you know, one thing liberalism should be is self
它发生的那些程序，无论它们最初的意图有多好，或者现在有多好，都很容易被大公司所掌控，容易被特殊利益集团所掌控，容易被现有的房主所掌控。它们很容易被那些了解它们并且有资金参与其中的人所掌控。所以，你知道的，要非常专注地去审视：你通过法案的事情是否如你所愿那样发挥了作用，如果没有的话，再回去重新审视它。你知道的，我希望，你知道的，自由主义应该具备的一点就是自我
correcting and it often isn't. So to get back to the high speed rail project in California, which we talked about earlier, what changes to policy do you think would have made that project possible? What would have allowed us to build it much faster? There are some things here that are really straightforward. They should have exempted the high-speed rail from the California Environmental Quality Act or at least set limits on how difficult it would be to do that, how often it could be slowed down. But the problem is you're really dealing with something
纠错能力，而它往往没有。所以回到我们之前谈到的加州高速铁路项目，你认为政策上的什么改变会使那个项目成为可能？是什么能让我们以快得多的速度建造它？这里有些事情非常直接。他们本该将高速铁路豁免于《加州环境质量法案》（CEQA），或者至少对这样做会有多困难、它能被放慢速度的频率设定限制。但问题是，你真正面对的是某种
that implicates the system itself. It's not any one bill, it's a whole way of doing things that we just got used to. And so it would have been a good idea to go to the French and say, how do you do this? And how might we follow along here? One of the things that has been very interesting to me in the past couple of years
牵涉到系统本身的东西。它不仅仅是哪一项法案，而是我们已经习惯了的一整套做事方式。因此，去找法国人并问他们“你们是怎么做到的？我们该如何在这里效仿？”会是一个好主意。过去几年里让我感到非常有趣的一件事是，
is that there are a bunch of places where something has gone wrong very fast, like the I-95 bridge collapse in Pennsylvania. And in Pennsylvania, there was a version of this in Maryland, there have been versions in California. The governors have used emergency declarations and been able to rebuild very, very fast. The I-95 story, which I tell in the book, they rebuilt that in 12 days when they thought it would take more than a year. And I think there is something interesting here to ask, which is that if all these governors,
有许多地方事情很快就出了问题，比如宾夕法尼亚州的I-95号州际公路大桥倒塌。在宾夕法尼亚州，马里兰州也有过类似的情况，加州也有过类似的情况。州长们使用了紧急状态宣言，并能够非常非常快地重建。我写在书中的I-95号公路的故事，他们认为这需要一年多时间，结果他们在12天内就重建了。我认为这里有一个有趣的问题要问，那就是，如果所有这些州长——
and Newsom has told me about his pride in emergency reconstruction, if all these governors are so proud of how much they can get done and how fast they get it done using emergency powers, well then, what does that say about your normal process? What would it mean to align not everything to what you can do in an emergency, but more that is a major priority to the discretion you give yourself during an emergency?
纽森曾向我讲述过他对紧急重建的自豪感，如果所有这些州长都为他们利用紧急权力能完成多少工作以及完成的速度有多快而感到自豪，那么，这说明了你们的正常程序有什么问题？这意味着，不是让所有事情都去适应你在紧急情况下能做的事，而是将更多你在紧急情况下赋予自己的自由裁量权，作为一项重大的优先事项？
Because is climate change really not urgent? It's only urgent if it happens fast. Is the housing crisis really not urgent? It's only urgent if it happens fast. Is the housing crisis really not urgent? It's only urgent if the housing burns down. So we've ended up in this system where we know the government can work fast because we see it do so when it declares an emergency. But otherwise it is completely wrapped itself in red tape. So I think that the answer I'd give because there's no just one answer, but look at the places or the processes where you think you are building well. Go look at other countries, go look at other cities, go look at yourself.
因为气候变化真的不紧急吗？只有当它发生得很快时，它才紧急吗？住房危机真的不紧急吗？只有当房屋被烧毁时，它才紧急吗？因此，我们最终陷入了这样一个系统：我们知道政府可以快速运转，因为我们看到它在宣布紧急状态时就是这么做的。但在其他情况下，它完全把自己包裹在繁文缛节之中。所以我给出的答案是——因为没有单一的答案——去看看那些你认为自己建设得很好的地方或程序。去看看其他国家，去看看其他城市，去看看你们自己。
When you've had these moments where you can wipe away some of this accumulated crust and make decisions about with discretion, which processes to keep and which to jettison. And then build something new off of that. Use that not as something you only use in the breach, but use it as a basis for a new model. Ezra, it's been a pleasure to talk with you. The book is called Abundance. I really appreciate your time.
当你经历这些时刻时，你可以抹去一些积聚的陈规陋习，并根据自由裁量权做出决定：保留哪些程序，抛弃哪些程序。然后在此基础上建立新的东西。不要把它当成只在危机时才使用的东西，而是要把它作为新模式的基础。埃扎，和您交谈非常愉快。这本书叫《丰裕》（Abundance）。非常感谢您抽出时间。
Thank you so much, Roman. Always, always great to hear from you. ["DELAYNE HALL AND EDITED BY COMMITTEE"] 99% Invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall and edited by Committee, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Riau. Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Colestead is the digital director of the rest of the team, includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald,
非常感谢你，罗曼。能听到你的声音总是、总是那么棒。[“德莱尼·霍尔和委员会剪辑”] 本周的《99%无形》由德莱尼·霍尔制作，由委员会剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐由斯旺·里奥创作。凯西·图是我们的执行制片人。科尔斯特德是其余团队的数字总监，成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃mett·菲茨杰拉德、
Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Dawn, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of this logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown Oakland California. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉什玛·道恩、凯利·普赖姆、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森以及我罗曼·马尔斯。这个标志的99%由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员，现在总部设在美丽的加州奥克兰上城潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。